ilan buzzati christian dufour michel ces
objets bonsoir bonsoir petit tour de
table sur marc-andré bédard
celle ci oblige commencé avec vous vous
l'avez bien connu je me suis mon père
journaliste me l'avait présentée je t'ai
devoir 12 13 m avait dit lui il très
près de l'évêque
c'est un homme important et bonjour par
lesdits des centaines de fois après dans
le cadre de mon travail puis toujours
prenez le temps de parler pour le temps
d'expliquer est vraiment un homme
remarquable celle ci écoutez moi j'étais
à québec comme journal et j'avais un
gros 1 3 ans qui travaillait pour la
gazette vécu beaucoup de votes à buriner
là et ils prennent le temps d'expliquer
il prenait le temps de te parle à tout
le monde quand je lis revu après il se
remémorait tout ça et moi ce que je veux
souligner c'est de ne pas quel gentleman
il était depuis deux ans le courage
politique de cet homme blanc m dans la
charte des droits du québec on en a
parlé plus tôt la rue l'orientation
sexuelle comme motif interdit
discrimination dans les années 70 cela
s'est toujours pas dans chambres
fédérales ces affaires là ça prenait du
courage politique
retirer les poursuites contre le docteur
morgentaler au mépris de la loi puisque
la loi disait que l'avortement était
toujours illégal et il l'a fait et il
l'a fait parce qu'ils ont peut pas
trouver jurés pour condamner cet homme
là puis je disais je tends concerne la
terre vient d'une région et conserva pas
mon oeil la ministre la justice et au
sein de la rule
alors si madame payet on a parlé de
manama voilà les raisons tant les
besoins de la famille les railhawks ilan
payet a réussi à faire l'assurance
automobile c'est son projet réel bien
sûr et c'est mieux c'est juste sais
c'est pas là pour tirer avec le barreau
qui perdait une grande partie sont
chanteuses de beaucoup d'avocats perdait
littéralement la bleue appelle ça
marcherait pas alors le musée justice et
dans toutes les autres dossiers aussi et
ils prenaient pas le crédit politique de
ça mais il a fait un travail
extraordinaire non seulement comme une
injustice mais dans toutes sortes de
dossiers
oui christian un mot sur monsieur bénard
ou moi je viens de chicoutimi et puis
tout ce qu'ils savent que c'est
l'institution au saguenay lac saint jean
marc andré bédard et le donner beaucoup
de crédibilité au pécule
j'en avais beaucoup besoin parce que
c'était quelqu'un de passionné comme on
le dit mr pas un énervé ce test un
conservateur un certain niveau mais un
conservateur de bon aloi qui quatre
points qui étaient pas énervé et je
trouve que c'est vrai qu'il était prêt
de rené lévesque je suis qu'à la fin tu
es un côté institutionnel qui donne très
vite ce n'est pas hasard sur le mobile
est ce que je sais c'est vraiment les
débuts du pq en fait qu'une sans
rappeler qu'on leur est pas radoter sur
ce qu'on dit monsieur bouchard et madame
marois et le michel donc c'est une vraie
perte ça rappelle toute une époque en
fait entre pour les pays qui ont les
péquistes mais aussi pour tous les
québécois
oui mais oui moi je voulais revenir sur
cette question de l'avortement parce
qu'il a beaucoup contribué à instaurer
ce droit-là fortement 1976 c'est encore
illégal de se faire avorter mais
monsieur henry morgentaler qui étiez
clinique à montréal est acquitté pour la
deuxième fois par un jury et plus tard
il se fait condamner mais par des juges
en cours d'appel et monsieur bédard
constate yeux la loi fédérale n'est pas
au diapason de la population et il dit
bon essentiellement ça ne sert plus à
rien d'essayer de la faire appliquer
c'est le qu'il donne cette consigne à
ses procureurs de ne plus déposer
d'accusations on est un grossiste et en
avant qu'à ottawa la cour suprême est
valide cette loi juste pour vous donner
un petit conte est un petit peu l'idée
du contexte en 73 on avait encore des
opérations policières ou par exemple un
couple de paul ii deux policiers
montréalais se faisait passer pour un
couple désireux d'apporter le fruit de
leur amour
et là on était en plein sur la planche
d'appel à la table d'opération vélo par
ils sortaient leur badge pour pouvoir
arrêter monsieur morgan thaler ça vous
donne à quai une idée à quel point cette
loi là l été on se contentait de la
faire appliquer donc que monsieur bédard
vient de dire à son monde
non on essaie de déposer des accusations
c'était révolutionnaire
très bien alors ils nous regardent je
lui disais de 11 et en gare de
du ciel parce qu'il a il a toujours
tenté d'élever les débats politiques et
ces deux là qui nous regardent
aujourd'hui la les vaccins je recommence
avec vos élèves à ottawa l'opposition
n'arrête pas d en vingt ans on sera pas
servis les premiers
est ce qu'il y a est-ce que ça
embarrasse vraiment ou pas dans quelle
mesure ça vient embêter monsieur trudeau
mais c'est lent bête parce que les gens
comprennent ce que l'opposition dit et
le gouvernement libéral fidèle à
lui-même et pas très bon pour expliquer
son point de vue il s'en remet toujours
aux mêmes lignes et ça vient donner
l'impression qu'il a quelque chose à
cacher mais ce qu'on oublie toujours
dans des baux lost et que ces vaccins
j'en ai encore aucun qui ont été
approuvés par santé canada longue même
si on recevait des doses on en est pas
encore mais si on n'en recevait on ne
pourrait pas les administrés encore on
pense que le processus irait vite mais
on en lui quand même pas là et il faut
pas oublier non plus pour l'instant
trois vaccins qui semble être prometteur
mais qui tous trois réclament des des
manipulations entre des conditions
d'entreposage très différentes les unes
des autres et donc c'est un peu normal
qu ottawa ne soient pas capables
d'élaborer un plan tout de suite parce
que la logistique est très différente
des vaccins alors on va écouter on va
écouter monsieur trudeau qui répond à
monsieur au toulon victimes surtout le
monsieur trudeau et on revient après dix
mois le premier ministre admet qu'il n'a
pas de place est ce que le premier
ministre va rendre public son plan de
destruction des vaccins et k
[Applaudissements]
dans depuis les débuts nous vivrons sur
un plan pour protéger les canadiens ce
plan nous a amenés à avoir le meilleur
portfolio de vaccins de tous les pays du
monde avec plus de doses par capita que
n'importe quel autre pays
nous avons fait le travail pour avoir
accès aux vaccins et maintenant son
entrain travers le travail avec les
provinces
alors christian où j'en ai dans
l'analyse des opérations vaccin va me
suis-je le seul canadien à trouver que
c'est humiliant pour le canada en fait
l'émission initiale de monsieur trudeau
parce qu'ils étaient transparence normal
on écoute et on a le paul d'industrie du
vaccin au canada se trouve que le canada
alors d'un pays de second ordre de dinde
aussi qui est quand même plus crucial et
puis moi j'ai le souvenir qu'elle canada
que j'ai eu une industrie pharmaceutique
centrée au québec en bonne partie aux
textes l'un des fleurons québécois
sur le plan économique l'industrie
pharmaceutique rouge a reçu patrick gens
sinon vous êtes découragé
on a plus parce qu'on en a déjà eu on a
plus de capacités de produire à grande
échelle des vaccins ya plus de
succursales qui produit son québec
celle ci est d'accord michel c alors
j'espère que les américains se sentent
comme citoyens de pays de secondaire
parce que le vaccin contre la grippe les
produits au québec et pour payer vendu
largement aux états unis on n'a pas la
capacité de produire ce vaccin est là et
on ne peut pas changer laboratoire comme
celui qui crée du vaccin pour la grippe
comme sauboires pour en faire un autre
mais ça c'est seulement mondialisée on
peut aimer ou pas aimer mais c'est comme
ça maintenant
l'un porte où sa passion tout produire
vous dites voilà d'une part puis enfin
pour pousser des bananes et d'autre part
ce qui est important dans cette chose là
c'est d'abord on est un nombre suffisant
de vaccins et espère voiliers qui en ont
acheté ta axa c'est justement ça chacon
a dès qu'on ne les produits répondent et
d'autre part il faut que la logistique
soit parfaite et ça c'est compliqué
parce qu'il faut qu'on crée je sais que
c'est une erreur humaine bête
c'est le concierge après le clip legros
frigidaire et là on peut pas donner de
vaccins cette journée là
c'est ça ça va être très difficile ça va
être juste pour le fédéral serait
difficile pour les provinces sont en
bonnes âmes et des généraux la tête de
ça sa voix est extrêmement bas gc non on
avait dominé ce que savait qu'il va y
avoir une haute responsable aussi là
mais à la fin ça c'est extrêmement
compliqué puis va y avoir des ratés
c'est inévitable hélène on ne sait pas
car vous l'avez rappelé d'ailleurs il
faut quand même rappeler aux gens il n'y
a aucun des vaccins qui n'est prêt
actuellement demain matin alors on peut
peut-être et on inclut les approbations
n'ont pas été données par année n'a pas
encore donné l'approbation faut quand
même le dire mais ça s'en vient pas mal
bien ténue oui oui parce qu'une chose
qui est importante à dire c'est que dans
tous ses contrats d'approvisionnement
que ottawa au ciné il y à un échéancier
de livraison alors c'est pas comme si on
va attendre que tous les américains
reçoivent le vaccin alors après après
quoi le canada recevrait ses doses dans
les contrôles ça dit on vous garantit un
certain nombre de doses je suis
tellement est tellement le chiffre de 6
millions de doses d'ici le 31 mars
circulent il n'a pas été confirmée mais
il ya beaucoup de monde qui en parlent
donc je commence à penser qu' il est
peut-être et je le dis parce que là le
problème c'est qu'on sait pas lequel
vaccin sera approuvée en premier et se
reprennent alors il ya peut-être un
chiffre dans un contrat et de 1 dans
l'autre et mon épaule contrat s'active
mais il faut quand même garder à
l'esprit que on ne sait pas encore c'est
quoi le taux de vaccination qui nous
permettra de déconfinement oui je
comprends qu on s'insurge ne pas être
vaccinés un mois où commence à être
vacciné un mois ou deux mois après les
états unis
mais ça veut pas dire que on va attendre
un mois ou deux mois de plus avant
d'être des confiné parce que cette
vaccination le vote durer plusieurs mois
patrick même toute l'année et il faudra
attendre plusieurs mois avant qu'on
découvre et rendu là la capacité
production aura tellement augmenté que
ça fera peut-être même plus de
différence
oui c est une raison plus j'admire le
fait qu'il est très très informés mais
je trouve faut pas sous-estimer en fait
ce que vont ressentir les canadiens
pendant les quelques semaines pendant le
mois le mois et demi où on va voir les
foyers des autres pays à être vaccinés
puis nous on se reporte faut pas
sous-estimer comment va sens
à ce moment là au delà de toutes les
techniques à l'istp contrat tout seul
une réalité brute michel physique ont
fourni le vaccin de la grippe ou saisies
moi je changeais n'importe quel vaccin
de la grippe contre le vaccin de la
coved
sur le plan politique ça va voir grosse
un impact parce qu'on va se sentir les
autres vacciner du combattant oui mais
est-ce qu'il arrêtait réalise c'est ça
la question de quotas constate
effectivement que pour son auditoire
parce que la france en a la grande
bretagne en allemagne en à michel ont
des capacités de production de ce genre
de ont des ateliers enfin des ateliers
des laboratoires satellite des géants et
on en a pas on a autre chose ça peut
être frustrant mais elle a fait je pense
pas que étant donné le nombre de vaccins
qui ont été achetés tous à l'égalité de
la population seront pas vaccinés
beaucoup plus tard au canada qu'ailleurs
même si ça commence un peu plus tard
qu'ailleurs cela dit je suis heureux je
les dis y'a je vais le répéter je
comprends pas que sur une autre ils sont
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne faisaient pas
prévu ça ya trois mois mais bon ça c'est
son problème et il vivra avec les
problèmes politiques et avec sa wii et
hélène un petit une session avec la
presse de briefing technique su fermer
dans une pièce si c'est elle compagne et
on a d un million de doses telle date 2
millions d'eau je pense que partenariés
comme le partage d'informations dans une
crise non et oui puis en fait il faut
quand même le souligner qu'on a moins
d'informations que dans certains autres
autres pays par exemple les états unis
par exemple on ne sait pas combien on a
payé pour ses pour réserver ses doses
alors que ces chiffres là pour la
plupart sont connus au sud de la
frontière
j'imagine que ceux des contrats des
clauses de confidentialité qui ont été
ajoutées mais on peut se demander
pourquoi c'est là mais semble-t-il que
les contribuables ne seraient en droit
de savoir combien on a payé pour tout ça
très bien merci
une chaîne voulez vous me parlez de
maradona n'a pas prévu il y est vous
voit en deuil
parce que je souhaite vous êtes un
champion à moins d'un changement mais
vous êtes un champion spectateurs
écoutez c'est un grand joueur et c'est
c'est eh
c'est un grand joueur et un grand joueur
qui avait aussi des grandes qualités des
grands défauts tout le monde va se
souvenir qu'elle mène ce cadre du but du
bic à porter avec une mère d'isabelle
c'est la main de dieu qui le fais plus
rien asseoir les a pas de reprise
électronique
mais c'est aussi quelqu'un que lui les
problèmes de drogue les problèmes
d'alcool qui est mort lié pas mort sur
la paille mais il est mort pauvre riche
et c'est un peu pour ça je pense que les
argenté pensent encore que c'est le
meilleur par joueur qu'il n'y a jamais
eu même si lionel messi qui jouent
encore on a compté beaucoup plus de bus
dans les ligues européennes que maradona
qui est un peu un flop en europe pour
eux maradona c'est le héros national
c'est lui qui a gagné la coupe du monde
est libre toujours s'en souvenir et
charismatique aussi la main de dieu ça
c'est notre but ok merci à vous trois
c'est très gentil merci j'apprécie à
bientôt au revoir bonsoir